australian scientists say they've
developed a pain-free
low-cost way to test blood sugar levels
in people with diabetes
it's all down to a non-invasive strip
that checks glucose levels
through a person's saliva researchers
say the material which detects glucose
can be printed
at a low cost they're hoping it'll
replace the current
needle-based blood test let's bring in
paul dastor he's a professor of physics
at the university of newcastle in
australia
and led the team who created the test he
joins us via skype from newcastle
paul good to have you with us so look
scientists start describing this as the
holy grail
of blood sugar testing non-invasive
pain-free
you led the team that made this trip how
revolutionary is it do you think
well we think it's going to make a
massive difference darren to
millions of diabetics around the world
um being able to now test your blood
sugar with your saliva
rather than your blood opens up the door
to pain-free
testing something that actually hinders
the
successful treatment of diabetes full
stop yeah and that's an important point
you make paul because type 1 diabetics
usually
have to prick themselves with a pin up
to five times a day to draw blood
and that's led many patients to cut
corners and minimize their daily tests
because it is painful as you say
you're absolutely right so imagine
instead that you're able to simply
use your saliva to test your glucose
levels
without any needles that's what we've
been working on for the past 20 years
and and so paul how does this new strip
actually work and what is it
about saliva that can tell us about our
blood sugar levels
okay so the materials that we work with
are remarkable they are electronic inks
these are polymers that can act as
electronic materials
but the difference is that we can print
them and we can print them at massive
scale using
reel-to-reel printers the same sort of
printers that you'd use to make
newspapers
your saliva has glucose in it and that
glucose concentration
follows your blood glucose but it's at a
concentration
about 100 times lower so what this means
is that we've had to develop a test
that's low-cost
easy to manufacture but has a
sensitivity about a hundred times
higher than standard blood glucose test
um i mean this strip
seems pretty obvious paul but i mean
what sort of challenges briefly did the
team face
in bringing it well we've had to develop
the entire technology it's based around
being able to
print transistors into which we embed
biomolecules and the biomolecule that
we've embedded into this
sensor this transistor is the enzyme
that detects glucose
so being able to understand how that
interaction works
how that can detect glucose and change
the electrical
performance of those transistors and
then being able to manufacture
has been a huge challenge most recently
it's just been announced that we have
secured funding to build the first
factory to manufacture hundreds of
millions of these sensors
here in australia just a final thought
to you paul before you go
i mean this new strip we understand is
still
uh in the clinical trial stage in
australia
when are we likely to see it come to
market then
we anticipate that it'll be on shelves
within about two years time
all right paul dustol good to get your
thoughts thank you very much indeed for
talking to al jazeera thank you
thank you very much